récupérer c'est recommandé poster des
colis ou encore à franchir ces courriers
tous les jours de 9h à 20h c'est
désormais possible
début juillet le nouveau coccinelle
express de montigny le bretonneux a
ouvert un relais poste dans l'enceinte
de son magasin davantage pour les gens
ils viennent ici si on verse à sur cette
épreuve je dois faire des opérations qui
font à la poste 7 sur 7 pendant les
horaires d'ouverture du magasin pour
accomplir ses nouvelles tâches les
employés du supermarché ont suivi une
formation pour apprendre à gérer les
services postaux
une initiative née peu de temps après la
fermeture du bureau de poste du quartier
du plan de trous pour les habitants du
quartier ce point poste représente un
véritable gain de temps
c'est très pratique ça évite de courir
jusqu'à la poste de la gare et c'est
vrai que c'est ouvert jusqu'à batteur et
moi des fois je rentre à 19h 19h30 et
c'est vrai c'est vraiment pratique de
déposer un courrier ou venir chercher
son courrier ici un distributeur de
billets devraient également être
installés prochainement dans le magasin
actuellement 17 points poste relais ont
vu le jour dans les yvelines